l'avion le maté les ballons d'or le
drapeau argentin c'est avec ces symboles
que le paris saint germain a confirmé la
nouvelle que toute la planète soccer
attendait
34 ans l'icône lionel messi jouera
maintenant dans la ville lumière pour
les supporters du fc barcelone c'est la
pire fin possible pour la période la
plus fructueuse du club
un divorce provoqué non pas par des
facteurs sportif mais bien par une
mauvaise gestion ce qui a fait fondre le
joueur en larmes au moment de dire au
revoir le club catalan n'a pas pu
renouveler le contrat de messi le fc
barcelone a laissé son budget salarial
explosé ces dernières années et la ligue
espagnole impose désormais des
restrictions financières strictes à ses
équipes
le paris saint germain c'est un cadeau
tombé du ciel le plus grand joueur du
monde libre comme l'air ira rejoindre
une équipe toute étoile avec notamment
son ancien complice du barça le
brésilien neymar est la pépite française
qui lie en bap et le trio d'attaquants
de classe mondiale qui séduira sans
l'ombre d'un doute de nombreux partisans
être l'euphorie
intérieurement et sur moi près par les
faits de match je pense qu'on va scander
son nom et tout c'est quand même une
légende qui arrive c'est mon joueur
préféré
je suis un fan de barcelone
avec l' embauche de messi tahrir evra
encore d'une conquête de la ligue des
champions c'était après tout l'objectif
avoué du club quand des investisseurs du
qatar en ont fait l'acquisition en 2011
la gloire sportive qui leur a échappé de
peu il ya deux ans mais aussi la
réussite commerciale messi sera présenté
mercredi à paris et devrait signer une
entente de deux ans avec le plus grand
joueur du monde dans son effectif le psg
va continuer d'étendre sa bonhomie tous
les chapitres ici olivier tremblay radio
canada montréal